okay  wow so apparently some students have  recorded images of the trans teacher at  Oakville Trafalgar High School which is  just outside of Toronto which is where  I'm from this video thank goodness good  for that student for putting this video  up the fact that the school is able to  and supportive of somebody like this  is insane I would say it's actually an  insult to trans people to call that  person a trans person they're wearing  giant prosthetic boobs with prominent  nipples that's their version of a woman  which is verging on misogynistic and I  think the most upsetting thing about  this is we have similar hair which is  which is which is just awful